ERAN FEIGENBAUM: Welcome to
Atmosphere Digital Rethinking
Security in the Cloud.
I'm Eran Feigenbaum, Director
of Security for Google Apps.
We have this great
panel here of experts
through all across Google
to talk about security.
Information security
has become such
a hot topic with the
increase in cyber crime,
the trends in privacy, the
changes in regulations.
It's something that
businesses can't ignore.
Enterprises all over the world
are concerned about security.
And to have a great conversation
about information security,
we've brought in four different
experts from all across Google,
each a subject matter
expert in security
in their own specific domain.
To my far left here, I have Tim
Willis from our Chrome Security
Team.
Next up is Adrian Ludwig.
Adrian is responsible
for Android security.
To my far right is
Stephan Somoygi Stephan
is a product manager in
our security and privacy
engineering team.
To my immediate right
is Suzanne Frye.
She's the Director of
Security, Privacy, and Trust
for Google Apps engineering.
The move of business to cloud
computing has really increased.
Companies see the
benefits of lower cost,
but also the ability
to innovate faster
for users to collaborate.
But one of the big
areas of hesitation
is security right
Companies are not
comfortable putting their
own data into the cloud.
How would you respond to
somebody that had that concern?
SUZANNE FREY: I think we're
seeing a real sea change right
now with respect to
people understanding
that the cloud is more secure
than any on-premise solution.
If you just think about
it, mathematically, you've
got all these different
on-premise solutions
and individual teams trying
to do the right thing.
And with any cloud
provider, you have the locus
of the best talent, the
best expertise centered
on making your solutions
secure and your data secure.
If you take a look
at our customer base,
we have some of the
world's largest banks.
We have some of the most
stringent government customers.
We're FedRAMP certified
here in the US.
And the fact that we
can solve for security
for all those customers
is a great testimony
to our capabilities.
But in addition, we solve
for something special.
In talking to our
customers, it's
our ability to innovate
and to bring new ideas
to bear that help enable them
to be competitive, productive,
and truly novel, and focus on
the things that matter to them.
That's part of our really
special secret sauce.
And I often say to
people at Google,
security comes in two forms.
It's both traditional
cybersecurity,
but it's also security against
technological stagnation.
ERAN FEIGENBAUM:
That's interesting
because we don't usually think
of that second one very often.
We tend to think of
the data security.
That's great from a
cloud perspective.
How does that change in the
Android or mobile world?
ADRIAN LUDWIG: I
like that observation
about being too
focused on security
to the exclusion of innovation.
I hadn't seen that
phrase that way.
But I think one of
the changes that we've
seen in the mobile space
over the last few years
is that companies are
focused, first and foremost,
on innovation, Android being
a great example of that.
But we've tied into
a security model
that is how people actually
consume applications
and services.
So we thought about the web
and the sandboxing model that
was used on the web, and we
incorporated that in the way
we built applications
sandboxing.
And I think the consequence
of that is cloud services
are becoming more
and more important.
Most applications that
are built for Android
have built for mobile regardless
of your mobile platform
are really cloud based.
So I think those two are tied
together, because both of them
are thinking about innovation
first and foremost,
and the security is sort
of unlock that innovation.
ERAN FEIGENBAUM: So
it seems like cloud
is actually and mobile
as a reason for companies
to move to those environments.
Is there stuff that Google's
doing that others really can't?
TIM WILLIS: I think
it's important to think
of the context in which
we're talking in here.
So we have a complex
set of systems
that we're dealing with today.
They get more and more
complex over time.
We also have adversaries
with increasing levels
of sophistication.
So you've got that on one
side, and on the other side,
we've got IT managers having
to defend their networks.
The problem with
defenses you need
to defend everything
incredibly well.
Attackers only need to find
one hole into your network.
So I think that's where
an advantage of moving
to the cloud is that
you have dedicated teams
with robust experience.
I mean, Stephan and I were
talking about this earlier
that some of the
people who I work with
wrote my textbooks
in university.
And it's one of
those things that I
get to work with these experts
and that's all they do.
They focus on
security, and that's
one of the huge benefits,
in my point of view,
of moving to cloud that's great
while we're protecting data
while it's at Google but we
have to do a lot of stuff
to make sure the data
safe when it's not Google
STEPHAN SOMOGYI:
Safe Browsing would
be a good example
of something that we
can do at very, very large
scale, where we actually
believe that the
right approach is
make the entire internet safer.
So we build systems that
hunt around and find malware
and find phishing and then
we go and report this.
And so an individual
consumer can
benefit from this, because the
web browser will let them know.
In a cloud environment,
enterprises
can take advantage
of this data as well
and keep themselves protected,
and we take this approach
through a number of
different areas, certificate
of transparency being
another example,
where we're taking a look
at the internet as a whole
and finding ways to
keep it safe at scale.
ERAN FEIGENBAUM: So obviously
in working with various experts
and then you guys are all
experts in your field,
right this encourage us to
innovate and come up with lots
of security innovation.
Some of those really
actually go beyond
and change security and
really move the needle
from what users are used to.
Maybe you can all give me one of
those examples that we've done.
SUZANNE FREY: I'd like to talk
a bit about security keys.
Security keys have--
Are you going to--
TIM WILLIS: Oh, no don't.
[LAUGHING]
ERAN FEIGENBAUM: Wait you
got my collection with me.
You have multicolored ones.
SUZANNE FREY: Nice,
almost Google colors too.
STEPHAN SOMOGYI: Indeed.
You need a green one.
SUZANNE FREY: These
keys are fabulous.
For the longest
time, we have been
talking about two-factor
authentication
is critically important for
most organizations to implement.
And many customers use Google
Authenticator and other apps
like that to generate
a one-time pass code.
Those are great.
They're certainly
better than nothing.
However, a hardware-based
security key,
such as these, just quantum
leaps ahead in terms of they're
not hackable and they really
do protect our customers
from phishing in a
way that basically
the one-time passwords do not.
So.
TIM WILLIS: I think it's an
interesting point, Suzanne,
especially talking about
the not-so-glamorous side
of the things that we do.
One of those things
is encryption for me
like it may not seem
incredibly innovative
but we're working
really hard to make sure
that all of our
traffic is encrypted
at rest and at transit,
and one example
where we're being open with
that is our HTTPS transparency
report.
Now, you can go to that site
and you can see our progress
towards our goal of 100%
encryption in transit
through all of our products.
Again, another example would
be working with TLS 1.3.
That's the next generation
of transport security.
Now, it may not sound
glamorous, but we're not only
helping to implement
that, we're helping author
the next version, so that
shows that we're in the mix
and we know what technologies
are around the corner.
A practical application of that
would be progressive web apps.
So these low friction
web applications
which are designed to
help increase engagement
and have an app-like experience
for customers and businesses.
We've seen studies how
that increases engagement.
And it's fantastic.
It's easy across the board.
Why am I talking about it?
Well, TLS is actually a hard
requirement for those apps.
So it's one of
these things where
not only are we innovating,
we're making sure that security
is baked in from the get go.
And I think that's one
huge advantage of Google.
ADRIAN LUDWIG: There's a
couple elements about that
that are interesting to me.
One of them is it's not so
much that the security itself
is innovative, it's about
using an innovative product
to make security available.
One of the things that we
did early on with Android
is we thought about the
platform stack and go OK,
you need to have verified boot,
you need to have encryption,
you need to have sandboxing.
Those are all, I think at
this point, almost commodities
for an operating system.
But one of the things that
Google brought to bear
was security services.
It's going to be a
cloud-connected device,
and we're going to make
all of those services
available by default
on all of the devices.
And so we started
thinking about how
do you bind services into
the operating system itself.
So we added things like
safety net and verify apps
where there are effectively
hooks in the operating
system where we can make
sure that we're adding
security dynamically over time.
So we can innovate in
security even more quickly
than we can innovate in the
operating system itself.
Does anybody know
that that's happening?
Not really.
But that's OK,
because they're safer
and they're happier
as a result of it.
So we the same way that
you guys are dealing
with TLS and progress web
apps, binding those two things
together just transparently
in the background.
STEPHAN SOMOGYI: On the
two ends of that spectrum,
there's also transparency.
And Tim, you're already talking
with the HTTPS Transparency
Report, but we've been
doing transparency
and we've been shining light on
ourselves for many, many years.
A couple years back, we did
the Safer E-mail Transparency
Report, where we were
looking-- first of all,
is there anything that we're
doing that we could do better?
And then having
looked at that, what
is the rest of the world
doing, and it's actually
moved the needle forward.
We are now in a
position to say yes,
as a result of shining a light
and illuminating the greater
situation on the
internet, more people
are using encryption
for their e-mail.
It happens across all of
our transparency reports
where first we look at ourselves
to see if we're doing the best
job that we possibly can,
and very often then we
cast our gaze more widely
in the outside world
to see what else is
out there and if we
can help people improve things.
ERAN FEIGENBAUM: Yeah.
Transparency actually
a really big part
of moving to the cloud.
Especially we see that a lot
with our enterprise customers,
right?
I mean.
SUZANNE FREY: Absolutely.
If you think about
it like anything,
if you don't know enough or
have sufficient information,
how in the world can
you make a decision?
How can you run your business?
And I do think that
transparency has
been one of the biggest
blockers to adoption
across all cloud products.
We've been investing
in multiple areas
to ensure the transparency is
front-and-center to what we do.
We engage third-party auditors
to help ensure and provide
certifications against
certain standards
like ISO 27017 and 18.
Our fed grant process
is also disclosed
to the government and
leveraged uniquely
in terms of making sure
that across our company
we are aware of vulnerabilities
and addressing them quickly.
And I think just in general
providing information
to the end user
about whether or not
their employees have
had a password violation
or have had some
suspicious activity
or giving them greater
reporting detail.
And I'm the first to say
that we still have some work
to do in the
reporting front, and I
think every cloud provider
does, but we're working really
hard to improve the degree that
an administrator understands
everything that's happening
within their company
and can take appropriate action.
ERAN FEIGENBAUM:
So a lot of what
you guys all talked about,
whether it's transparency
for our enterprise customers
or for all users or some
of the innovation in
Android, we really wouldn't
have expected years ago.
I, at least, wouldn't
have predicted that.
You guys are all experts
and very deep in your field.
What would be your
security vision?
What's going to change?
What's going to make our
lives easier for our users?
STEPHAN SOMOGYI: I think
a lot of the security,
as we've talked before,
needs to stay invisible,
and in some cases, can be a
little bit counter-intuitive.
So a couple months
back, we released
a product called OnHub, which
is a home networking router.
And one of the things
that it's particularly
counter-intuitive
about it but which
is adding a lot more security
is the fact it's cloud managed.
So all the technology that we
devise to protect our users
accounts-- like Suzanne was
talking about with the security
key-- all of that benefits
the user because the Google
account is the way
the user starts
to manage their device at home.
So as we connect all the various
pieces of our security puzzle,
they all work together
and suddenly you
have a device at home
which is actually
cloud managed and
cloud secured, which
is not the way it was
even a few years ago.
There's a distinct
security benefit now.
ADRIAN LUDWIG: I'd like to talk
a little bit about the elephant
in the room with respect
to security, which
is this dynamic tension
between access to data
and keeping it secure.
One of the very hard
things for most enterprises
is to say listen,
someone else is
going to be the governor of
our data-- steward of our data,
perhaps I should say,
and what is that company
going to do with our data?
And I reference audit
reports and certifications
that we commit to every year.
However, machine learning is
one of the most exciting things
that's happening in the field
of computer science today.
And machine learning requires
training data to perform.
And obviously, with customers
sharing data with us,
we could just take
that data and go
nuts, which would be
irresponsible of Google
and would really kill
our vision overall.
But I do think
solving that problem
and putting our
customers in control
of what data we can use to
enhance the way that they work,
to improve productivity,
to reduce the cost,
and to understand how
competitive they are
in a global landscape for
a given industry-- that's
super-exciting stuff.
So I think finding that gentle
balance between making sure
that customers can maintain
absolute control over who
sees their data, when,
and uses it for what,
is one of the most exciting
problems we have to solve,
because it's going to bring
tremendous advances to mankind.
ERAN FEIGENBAUM: Wow.
That's impressive.
TIM WILLIS: I feel like
I'm the guy who's going
to talk about the boring thing.
I think it's really exciting
that more companies are moving,
I think, more deeply
into the cloud.
For some background,
before I joined Google,
I was the sysadmin
and an IT manager,
and so I caught
the security bug--
pun intended-- and ended up
joining an incidence response
team.
So a lot of what I was
doing was rolling out
to companies and departments who
were being hacked and helping
them clean up their networks
helping them rebuild up
their defenses and kicking
the miscreants out.
And it's one of these things
where as we mentioned earlier
it's just going to get more
and more sophisticated,
and it's harder that
moving to the cloud
actually buys you the Google's
security team in a sense.
It gives you the protection
that we're offering.
It lets you not have
to worry about that.
And one of the great advantages
of that is as an IT manager,
I don't have to
worry about that.
I can sleep a little
bit better at night
knowing that Google's got my
back when it comes to security.
ADRIAN LUDWIG: I think it's been
interesting talking with folks
and getting a little bit
different perspective.
Even in the last minute or
two, we've heard discussion
about hardware security,
and we talked about machine
learning, and pulling in
data from different places.
Google every conversation you
learn a little bit something
new.
And I think that's
one of the key things
that the security industry
is going through right now.
We're beginning to a
point where there's
enough maturation in
all of our products,
where there's enough data
that's being pulled in,
enough ability to
analyze that data,
where we can actually start
to make good decisions.
For generations, really,
from a technology standpoint,
we've been relying
on assumptions
about what good
security looked like,
which things you need to
be worried about, what
risk is likely to hit you.
But now that people are
moving to the cloud,
now that we have operating
systems like Android
where we're trying
to deploy security
solutions across the
entire ecosystem,
we get a lot of data.
We can analyze that,
and we can start
to make really good decisions.
So I think that's
the thing that I'm
most excited about
over the next few years
is we're going to
get to the point
where as professionals,
we can actually
understand risk and make really
good risk-based decisions,
which isn't something we've
been able to do in the past,
and it's not something
that is possible
if you're not in the cloud,
if you're not on mobile.
So that's what I'm
really excited about.
ERAN FEIGENBAUM:
The one thing that's
really in common with
everything everybody
said is having a large
security team that's capable
and has the expertise to
really ingest all that,
to be able to do the
things for you on the cloud
or to use all that
data that now we
have to make products
more and more secure
or to develop that
machine learning.
So hopefully, this was a
good insight for everybody
to hear what some of our
security leaders at Google
are thinking about,
what they're working on,
and what they're working
on in the future.
So thank everybody
for taking the time
and listening in to us.